here's Ana Navarro from The View what
else happens is
um I think overreaching and
overcompensating and just overdoing it
because to me when you are removing all
gender-specific words from the Oompa
Loompas I mean people the Oompa Loompas
are fictional yeah they're made believed
but you know when you're doing that kind
of thing it then it lends itself for
folks uh on the right to say oh this is
what Walt Disney is all about you've got
to be anti-work let's pass an anti-world
act let me tell you what I'm concerned
about I'm not concerned about you
editing out words from a book I think
that's stupid I'm concerned about you
editing out black history studies from
AP courses in Florida and I you know I
think it should make us feel
Anna
I'm gonna do it again I'm gonna write
down three words that I think about Anna
Navarro
going to fold it up
I'm gonna sign it
to
28 23 we will send this somebody after
the show
Anna okay she almost got it right there
she almost got it right that the woke
overreach with everything so we
shouldn't be concerned about so they're
doing too much by caring about Oompa
loompa's gender and sexuality and the
rest of it who would have thought in
2023 we'd be talking about Oompa
loompa's gender the Obama who were
incredible people and the fact that so
many of them escaped the snozz wangers
and that whole thing we don't have to
get into that right now but the point
guys is that then of course what does
she do
it's not about the people who are
changing the work and changing the
meaning of words and confusing everybody
and putting the the standards of 2023 on
works of the past what is it really
about it's about what's happening here
in Florida of which she completely Lies
We are not not teaching African-American
history it was one course that they
wanted to teach critical race Theory and
gender queer Therian and push for
reparations and a whole bunch more so
that a high school student learning that
would get college credit and DeSantis
said is enough she knows she's lying
everyone at that table knows she's lying
the producer knows she's lying and
everyone at ABC knows she's lying much
like Andrea Mitchell lied about this and
we played that clip last week and then
she gave that half-assed apology so at
some point you just have to know that
their job is to lie their job is to push
misinformation their job actually is to
do everything from that quote in 1984
that I just read to you
foreign
[Music]